in blackpool the board is up the seats
have been cleaned and most importantly
the cameras are ready for history to be
made
lisa ashton is the top seed for the
world match play event the first
professional darts corporation women's
tournament to be fully televised another
major step in the ongoing development of
women starts
it's massive achievement for the ladies
game with the first match play in
blackpool to be on the winter gardens
another step forward for us and for me
to be in in lancashire at blackpool
half an hour from home i couldn't ask
for anything better
in the 18 segments
queen of the palace fallon made a huge
breakthrough in 2019 when she became the
first female to win a match in the pdc
world championships
fallon's win i think really did open
doors i think people just wanted to see
more of you know the women up there more
of them playing so for us as i say to be
here and to have this opportunity is
just absolutely unbelievable
it's almost eerily quiet in here at the
moment but once the ladies take to the
stage the winter gardens will be buzzing
and this is what they're going to be
playing for the chance to be the first
to have their name on this spectacular
trophy as well as a share of the 25 000
prize port and a guaranteed place in the
grand slam of darts in november
today's tournament brings together
competitors from all corners of the uk
as well as the netherlands finest
and first up laura turner how do you
think that's going to go
the last couple of times are once
against laura but yeah you never know
every dart game is different
yeah we will see i know i can be there
but
i never say i'm gonna be there or
anything because darts is a crazy game
and we'll be seeing much more of the
ladies next year the pdc has already
announced that its women's series is to
be expanded to 24 events for the 2023
season
fraser moored sky news